on le connaissait acteurs mais pas
encore chanteur charles berling continue
de monter sur scène mais il est
désormais accompagné de musiciens la
chanson une envie à ces nouvelles pour
l'artiste ça fait une dizaine d'années
que j'ai recommencé à ma passion avec la
chanson que je dis recommencer parce que
au fond quand j'avais entre 14 et 20 ans
quand j'ai commencé ce métier au lycée
dumont-d'urville d'ailleurs à tous non
eh bien je faisais du théâtre du cinéma
en faisant des films super vite et de la
chanson et
ou les
s
les coeurs des faits
de ses chansons charles berling écrit
les paroles
un moyen pour lui de raconter une
histoire des maux causés sur le papier
et mise en musique par des
professionnels tels que robert le gall
ou encore yvan cassar ya une dizaine
d'années je me suis remis à écrire
beaucoup de paroles de chansons et après
j'ai démontré à des miliciens qui
semble-t-il est mêlé les paroles
puisqu'ils ont écrit des musiques dont
bertrand burgalat carla bruni philippe
jacot faberca haine et freddy qu est là
et j'en passe
le résultat sur scène c'est de la
chanson française qui tique un peu la
pêche quoi voilà c'est ça que j'adore
oui bah moi si je vais sur scène fait
pas pour m'endormir ou endormir les gens
le public pourra découvrir le jeune
chanteur à bois d'arcy à la grange de la
tramblais 19 janvier à 20h30
on a eu la chance de répéter la barre
une résidence ici pendant soit avec des
skis moyens techniques et les idées des
gens
très sympathique qui nous accueille la
salle est très bien et en plus y'a une
bonne acoustique attendus sont ceux qui
aiment la chanson française qui ont
envie de découvrir jeunes chanteurs mary
qu'ils viennent